foreign
welcome back to Harry Potter Theory
today we'll be discussing Ron Weasley
and all of the problems associated with
his wand A Wizard's wand is his most
important tool it's the conduit of his
power and for most the only way they'll
ever be able to conjure spells so if
ones were so important why did the
Weasley family decide to give Ron a
hand-me-down wand that never really
served him well in fact Ron's earliest
wand was so bad that many of his
instructors at Hogwarts could never
shake their first impression of the boy
that he was a subpar wizard so why
didn't Ron have his own wand why was he
given Charlie's and why did it take him
so long to get a new one we'll answer
these questions and More in today's
video Ron's first wand when we go back
to Ron Weasley's very first year we'll
find him in an awkward situation unlike
Harry Potter Hermione and most other
children on the Hogwarts Express Ron
wasn't adorned in a lot of new clothes
and he didn't possess many new items and
when the food trolley aboard the train
rolled by known then as the honeydukes
express Ron wasn't able to buy very much
in the Weasley household gallians and
sickles weren't easy to come by with one
of the largest families in the pureblood
community the Weasleys had more than
enough mouths to feed at one point Paul
Molly and Arthur Weasley Ron's parents
had to feed clothe and house seven
children Bill Charlie Percy Fred George
Ron and Jenny keeping up with all of
your children's peers was hard enough
when you had just one but the Weasleys
had seven they could hardly afford to
buy the greatest owls fanciest robes
almost powerful ones for each one and
when it became Ron's turn to attend
Hogwarts School of which coffin was a
dream the Weasleys seemed to finally
come up short instead of visiting
ollivander's one shop in Diagon Alley
they simply handed Ron one of the ones
from his older brother Charlie with that
in his hand and a trunk full of other
hand-me-downs the Weasley sent the
youngest boy off to school now when we
ask why the Weasleys would give Ron
Charlie's old wand I think the answer is
pretty obvious they didn't have enough
money or at least that's what we've been
led to assume but in that very same year
the Weasleys made some other odd choices
with their finances that might make you
question their reasoning to congratulate
Ron's older brother Percy for becoming a
prefect Arthur and Molly purchased him
an owl and robes now considering how
much trouble Ron had with magic and how
much this would affect his self-esteem
in the coming years investing so much in
Percy's presence seems a bit misguided
if the Weasley parents had spent more
time thinking about what Ron would need
in order to succeed in his classes than
they would have realized that perhaps
Charlie's old wand wouldn't be good
enough after all Garrick Ollivander said
it best when he claimed the wand chooses
the wizard that much has always been
clear to those of us who have studied
one law if you are any wizard at all you
will be able to channel your magic
through almost any instrument the best
results however must always come where
there is the strongest Affinity between
Wizard and wand these connections are
complex an initial attraction and then a
mutual quest for experience the ones
learning from The Wizard the wizard from
the wand it seems unlikely that Arthur
and Molly Weasley would have disagreed
with Ollivander on this point so their
choice to blow their education budget on
Percy's gifts seems all the more strange
in fact this has led many outside
observers to suggest that the Weasley
family wasn't poor because of a lack of
income but simply because they failed to
manage their money properly whatever the
case might have been Ron's first here at
Hogwarts was hardly that of a magical
Prodigy the combination of an
ill-fitting wand combined with the
pressure of his older brother's great
successors was all a bit too much for
Ron to handle
sure he provided his courage while
helping his close friend Harry Potter
protect the Philosopher's Stone from
Voldemort but Ron failed to make a
positive impression on his teachers it
didn't help that the two people he sat
next to every day in class Harry Potter
and Hermione Granger were among the most
skilled wizards of their generation
either breaking his wand but Ron's time
with Charlie's wand would be short-lived
on the day Ron was supposed to arrive
for the full semester of his second year
the youngest Weasley boy broke his wand
that was not the worst thing to happen
on the day but it would have the longest
impact on his ear
Ron was far too afraid of his parents to
report his broken one to them so for the
rest of the Year Ron simply suffered
through class with the wand that was
patched up and barely held together
throughout the year whenever Ron would
try to produce spells they would
regularly backfire or Worse cause so
much harm that he was sent to the
healers
once his wand even hit a professor
squarely on his head but Ron's first
wand was useful for one thing when
Professor gildoro Lockhart ripped the
magical device from the children's hands
and tried to use it to cast a memory
charm the wand did exactly what it had
done all year backfired instead of
wiping Ron's mind and those of his
friends it scrambled Professor
Lockhart's leaving him incapacitated for
the rest of his life
you wand but that run in with Professor
Lockhart was about as bad as things
would get for Ron at least when it came
to his ones before the start of Ron's
third year at Hogwarts his parents
bought him a brand new one from
ollivander's shop and his ability to
cast spells and perform magic
dramatically improved that year although
he was still a bit behind his friends
Harry and Hermione Ron was nothing like
he was during his second year with his
new wand Ron's confidence also grew and
he found himself a bit less burdened by
the legacy of his older brothers
confident and with a new wand in his
grasp Ron went on to become quite a
competent student and as Voldemort
shadow Rose and his Gathering Army of
Death Eaters struck out against Harry
Potter's allies Ron proved just how
capable he and his new wand were Ron
grew to be such a skilled spellcaster
that he even disarmed Bellatrix
Lestrange and he didn't even use his
wand to do it he had disarmed Peter crew
shortly earlier and use that former
Marauder's wand to get the jump on
Bellatrix which was no small feat she
was considered by many to be Voldemort's
most powerful follower after all she
managed to kill Sirius Black and was
more than lethal with her own wand
conclusion when we look back at Ron's
first wand it is oddly enough still a
mystery as to why his parents Arthur and
Molly decided to give it to him again as
we've said the obvious reason would be
the Weasley's unfortunate lack of
finances but that first wand certainly
put Ron on an uphill path without a
properly suited one from ollivanders
he'd never quite achieved the same
finesse with his spells that his peers
would and that would only compound his
already substantial self-esteem issues
the Weasley parents must have been
oblivious to just how much harm they
were doing to Ron when they gave him
Charlie's wand but if they had to do it
all over again hopefully they would have
decided to forego Percy's gifts and
would have brought Ron the perfect wand
for his first day at Hogwarts and that's
it for this video I hope you enjoyed
this deep dive into Ron's first wand and
the effects it had on his magical
abilities during his first few years at
Hogwarts what do you think do you think
Ron's self-esteem and by extension his
spell casting abilities were deeply
affected by his second-hand wand do you
think the Weasley parents made a poor
choice when they decided to give Ron his
Elder Brothers wand I can't help but
wonder if Ron could have surprised Us in
his first two years and learned to love
the classes at Hogwarts maybe he would
have taken after his older brother Percy
and discovered his knack for magic or
Ron would have simply felt a bit more
confident and wouldn't have been so
bothered when Draco and his goons teased
him in the corridors between classes
that alone would have been worth the
price of a new wand from all Avengers
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
foreign
[Music]